the search for a man in Oregon who
authorities believe was targeting
victims on dating apps is over
the suspect is now dead overnight police
and Benjamin Foster were locked in a
tense standoff for several hours until a
SWAT team stormed the home where he had
barricaded himself our Lilia Luciano was
in Grants Pass Oregon this morning with
us all unfolded I want to warn you some
of the details you are about to hear are
disturbing Lilia good morning
good morning to you David every detail
about the story is disturbing and we
hope to learn more from police like why
did that standoff end here at the
victim's house last night after a
week-long Manhunt what happened was that
police eventually found Benjamin Foster
hiding under that crawl space under the
house and that's when they closed in on
him
the Intensive search for Benjamin Foster
strangely ended where it began at a home
where police say he bound and tortured
his victim nearly killing her our
cameras were there during the standoff
s and bangs rang out on what neighbors
say is a usually quiet street in Grants
Pass a small city in Southwest Oregon
they approached behind large Shields
assembling in a line then moved in after
the standoff Foster was brought to the
hospital where police say he died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound on Tuesday
police posted a photo of Foster from
earlier in the day where you can see him
walking a dog in town that prompted law
enforcement to swarm the area last week
police got close to catching the 36 year
old some 20 miles away but he escaped
there they did charge a 68-year-old
woman accused of helping him get away
and warned the public that he was still
active on dating apps perhaps to find an
accomplice or another victim as this was
not the first time he was accused of a
crime in 2017 a partner accused him of
trying to strangle her and in 2019
Foster was charged with assaulting his
then girlfriend in her home in Las Vegas
tying her up for two weeks severely
beating her before she could Escape
Foster faced decades behind bars but
took a plea deal and was released from
prison the same day he arrived because
of time already served in jail
out of respect for the victim's privacy
we're not disclosing her identity but I
did hear back from some of her friends
who late last night expressed some
relief saying that Foster can no longer
hurt other women and that they just hope
their girl their friend wakes up that
she recovers Tony
yeah a lot of questions about that plea
deal Lilia thank you very much moving on
now to a sigh of relief in Omaha
Nebraska this morning after police took
quick action to stop what could have
become another mass shooting in this
country in a store filled with customers
police say that calls from 9-1-1 were
pouring in shortly before noon yesterday
when a white man in his 30s entered a
Target store and was firing from an
AR-15 style rifle that suspect was shot
dead by responding officers within six
minutes of those first calls for help
and according to the police chief the
suspect had plenty of ammunition had
they not arrived fortunately and
amazingly no one was hurt tragedy
averted there